[Música]
vamos ver se consigo usar isto a quem
fazer não vou fazer a minha apresentação
em inglês
muito menos em suaíli porque ninguém é
compreender leva é e começo a cruzar as
gostar delas e dizer diz que nada é mais
poderoso do que uma ideia é que siga na
altura certa
há cerca de três anos atrás eu tive uma
idéia ele alguma forma melhorar o mundo
e para treinar e equipar africa uma
série de pessoas que disseram que eu era
um idealista uma semeadora é uma top cá
e eu uma outra parte que disseram para a
áfrica mas é que ela falou heranças
aquilo é só a crise é só eu figurantes
criminal deve ser agora doutor zona de
conforto da sua casa em segurança ea
tetra foi para a áfrica
depois também aqueles que não têm aquela
visão mais trágica e dramática do oeste
fica lá no meio do evangelho do
terrorismo e do pacto e não me deu mais
vontade de ir sobre center é a estante
apenas gostaria de saber a quem muito
rapidamente uma com uma pequena costa
contestou a acusação de que essa idéia
não surgiu nada tanto desde quando meu o
meu próprio projecto profissional é pois
tempo do encontro com essa mesma idéia
nós podemos simplificar em geral ainda
que tivesse ideia é até implementação da
minha sina é podemos simplificar tudo em
seis partes quanto o primeiro passo foi
tirar a minha licenciatura em psicologia
e depois no final do ano
fui para um colégio do processo de
desenvolvimento em inglaterra enquanto
em todas as competências digamos que
mais formais mais teóricas para
futuramente poderá incluir no projeto em
áfrica é e depois em 2003 vem é que foi
de facto o primeiro grande passo para a
saída e com uma mochila às costas com
alguma capacidade financeira trabalhar
em inglaterra ferreira durante três
meses para para mombaça para mim e
grande primeira experiência como
voluntária e teve um orfanato em uma
escola e de facto tenho certeza que essa
idéia não é só algo que eu tenha
viabilizar a escrever todos em fila é
paralelamente também teve uma série de
coisas positivas vir alguma sorte que
dizer e tive a oportunidade de trabalhar
no ano seguinte numa uma energia em que
impera na maior favela urbanizada da
áfrica e 9 e fotografia de um estágio
das nações unidas está descrito pelo
facto não correu da melhor forma porque
na minha visão é minha do dia
completamente diferente da ideologia de
quem eu tinha criança apresentar e na
organização mas posto isto também acho
que já tem as condições necessárias para
transformar esta minha ideia de facto
numa coisa mais palpável e foi aí que
nasceu
inicialmente um projeto que sua loja e
que vera e depois agora formalmente a
sessão para tal
convém e gostaria de frisar que da parte
de todos nós temos ideias
todos nós temos ideias ea que nos liga
que de facto vidas podem ser ridículas
ou que não fazem sentido nenhum outro
não tem cabimento
mas o facto o eu acho que a partir do
momento que nós temos uma idéia que
acreditamos nela ninguém mais nos
preparar porque para além de nós
próprios confirmamos a palestra nós
próprios não conseguimos fazer grandes
coisas têm quebrado agora é
aí fora existem muitas mais pessoas com
os mesmos erros que nós temos com a
mesma maneira de pensar com a mesma
força de vontade que nós temos
e foi isso mesmo que aconteceu a
[Música]
diferença mesmo que aconteceu há
portanto nós temos sempre que fizer tudo
isto leva a que de facto eu encontrei
uma série de más pessoas como com mesmo
a mesma vontade é grande ajuda portanto
partir do porto galo até aqui minha eu
apenas estava lá é e e possam utilizar o
estudo numa frase do grande no enem que
diz que 'é uma cena do filme banana tier
one
portanto em 2014 eu decidi criar uma
página no facebook denominada de que
vera olhe é falar em sua renda e um dos
uma das línguas oficiais do quênia que
significa bater à porta e pedir licença
para entrar e nós temos então nesse caso
a pedir licença que libera para entrar e
para an fazer uma série uma série de
coisas e comem apenas vera que a partir
do momento que eu criei essa página foi
incrível é a quantidade de pessoas que
se inscreveu em maio busca que enviavam
mensagens que tentavam contactar a dizer
o que eu também tenho esse sonho também
está a fazer isto então o governo atua
pé lu eo incrível foi que tanto a página
teve assim num exponencial e todas essas
pessoas fizeram um com que de facto este
projecto pessoal transformar se num
projeto social e humanitário em que
juntas todos nós pensarmos em soluções
apresentamos ideias e programas para
tentar de facto inferir na capacitação e
na resolução dos problemas neste caso
que eram expostas e que entrava
diariamente no computador essas pessoas
através desta página do facebook
e juntos eo e mais 22 mil seguidores é
conseguir então vou fazer uma série de
mudanças positivas todas por forma a
promover o desenvolvimento e deixar que
atrocidades diárias a violação dos
direitos humanos das pessoas o é de
facto o que acontecerá e um desses
mesmos programas foi o programa de
apadrinhamento em que consistia e
consiste numa forma de conseguirmos
assegurar às crianças lá é o direito à
educação que devia ser um direito
completamente fundamental e ainda assim
porque através da educação é é educação
é a meu ver clara é uma das formas que
essas crianças têm de sair daquela
situação de miséria e de pobreza ele
conseguiu nem fazer de facto alguma
coisa neste mundo tanto nós garantimos
investimento em educação e 180 crianças
obviamente que as crianças e obviamente
também tentamos fazer auto duas famílias
é assim que os padrinhos aqui em
portugal fazemos essa ponte e faremos as
proteínas as crianças nos uniformes
brasil assegurando igualmente cuidados
médicos
neste momento 70 famílias estão a ser
estudadas
uma das outras formas que encontramos
para promover essa mesma
esse mesmo desenvolvimento da favela é
foi através deste programa de
microcrédito em que trabalhamos com mães
solteiras e desempregadas em que damos
uma pequena ajuda inicial d e e com isso
já conseguimos neste momento criar cerca
de 40 quarenta cinquenta postos de
trabalho e isso tem uma imagem do grupo
de mulheres perto através do
microcrédito
elas farão um trabalho e desta forma o
movimento que adaptado à cultura noé e
desta forma
consegue sustentar a família que
normalmente em média são constituídas
por 45 crianças convivem desculpa uma
das outras formas é esse problema da
alimentação neste momento nós estamos
implementando sooou programa entre as
escolas com as quais colaborar anos e
mais de 300 crianças - crianças estão a
ser abrangidos por este programa e é
muito importante frisar que é este
programa consiste em duas refeições
quentes por dia o que almoço e o almoço
e por que é tão importante assim o
programa porque a grande maioria destes
meninos quando chega a casa não tem
qualquer tipo de refeição até o próximo
almoço que vai ser a princípio nós na
escola é uma outra forma é que nós em
que nós encontramos até mesmo o
desenvolvimento foi no centro
comunitário em que brasileiros não
apenas as crianças mais pequenas mas
também os anunciantes e os adultos
isso é uma imagem do nosso primeiro
centro que conseguimos construir através
do android em fizemos agora temos de
momento é construir um segundo e também
conseguimos fazer este programa de
interessam com voluntários
a grande maioria delas nunca portugal já
fizemos alguns é que a imagem podem
enviar duas montarias uma delas ainda
está lá neste momento e que de facto a
fazer um trabalho excelente porque temos
que assumir que obviamente que ajuda em
casa portugal e e ajuda particularmente
em termos económicos monetários mas o
trabalho de campo é essencial que nós
não podemos ter nem toma um um tipo de
ajuda cara é só um tipo de ajuda lá
porque vai ajudar não queremos fazer
nada lá é uma estranha a jucá também é
ele o trabalho é feito ao movimento que
as coisas não podem viver é e para
melhor
neste momento o tal projecto que se há
pessoal passou a uma sessão legalmente
am formalizada e contamos nos próximos
dois anos
o ngd para isso já criamos a sessão já
temos o o quanto a direção formada
estamos a trabalhar num projecto em
termos da gestão orçamental no plano
anual de atividades todos os requisitos
que necessitamos facto para podermos
receber mais ajudas por exemplo em
termos de empresas neste momento só
temos ajuda sem título individuais e é
isso que nós contamos nos próximos nos
próximos dois anos faziam
já temos o sérvio da cisão também
funcionará em brega
neste momento estamos também fria temos
a tentar agregar mais doses para a
sessão e facto é ingênuo pontos é um eu
gostava de vos dizer duas coisas a
primeira é que independentemente de
qualquer que seja a nossa idéia
independentemente dos comentários toda a
gente não possa fazer que é ridículo não
tem qualquer tipo de fundamento etc etc
nós temos que acreditar em nós
acreditamos nessa idéia
nós acreditamos que a nossa ideia pode e
vai mudar o mundo e não vou falar só de
ganhos em termos humanitários qualquer
outro tipo de idéia
nós de fato acreditamos nessa idéia por
aí fora existem outros mais com nós e
juntos temos mais força e conseguiremos
de facto mudar o mundo
a segunda e daí a idéia de facto é
jogando aqui neste nesta imagem dos dos
três macacos é que nós não podemos nunca
é tapar os olhos fingir que não vimos e
não falar era e na fala ela não nos
podemos calar nós temos que nos voltar à
liga e do facto
neste momento a nossa system of nós
temos
enquanto a sessão nos focamos e esse
realmente é nestas entre as questões
essenciais nós tentamos combater estas
desigualdades
uma prova disso só o facto que estão em
terreno e que sabe melhor do que é que
está a falar
mas há de facto diariamente somos somos
invadidos por uma série de violações
atrocidade viu seus direitos humanos
então nós queremos continuar a luta
lucerna por uma melhora turma dignidade
de todas as pessoas
igualdade respeito oscilante e o que nós
queremos é que todos os seres humanos
tenham o mesmo as mesmas oportunidade e
com ele o mesmo desenvolvimento é para
finalizar deixo com esta frase do
cervantes que eu acho que o facto
sintetiza tudo o que foi dito e na minha
perspectiva tudo que tem que ser feito
mudar o mundo
nome que sem isso não é loucura não é
utopia é justiça
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]